-I think, for a lot of fans of
this show,
the most exciting thing was
the very fact that there was
a season 4 and that you were,
in fact, alive.
When were you aware that
your character had survived
season 3?
-Yeah, I was aware
the whole time.
It was -- It wasn't
a secret to me,
but, you know, any time
you have an ending like that,
then you make people wonder.
I think it's always
a good thing
because, you know,
people are always --
I think that's the great thing
about these streaming shows,
is that it always leaves you
wanting something, you know,
and I think it's human nature.
It's like why people like
soap operas.
You know, they want to see
what's going to happen
to Muffy and Biff, or whatever,
you know.
You know, once they announced
that there'd be a season 4,
obviously, everybody knew
that, you know,
I'm probably going to come back,
somehow.
But the way it's done
is pretty interesting,
and it actually started with
Larry Trilling,
who's the, you know,
show-runner,
director of the show,
who's a brilliant guy.
And I said, "Look, I'd love to
shoot in San Francisco
for the last season, and
I'd love to have some kind of
"Vertigo" vibe,
and that's what we did.
And there's a lot of sort of
spooky stuff in it
that's not your usual,
you know, linear storytelling.
You know, and in this case,
it's about the opioid crisis
in this country -- which we
have, [laughs] you know,
and it's a -- it's
a pretty heavy season,
and I think we ended it
on the right note.
I mean, you know,
sometimes I think series
go a bridge too far,
and you kind of want to end
on a high note,
you know,
or with your most powerful one.
And of course, you always want
to say the last season
was the best, but in this case,
I truly believe it is.
And I'd only signed up
to do four seasons
and we all agreed that,
you know what?
This is perfect to end it here
because, you know,
you don't want to be
struggling for a story
that beats that one
the next year and everything.
So I think we -- I think
we did okay on it.
-One of the other things you had
to keep topping with this show
is these incredible actors
who would come in
and play villains
over the course of the season.
You had Bill Hurt, Dennis Quaid,
Amy Brenneman last year,
and now J.K. Simming--
J.K. Simmons, excuse me,
and Bruce Dern.
Were those guys that
you'd worked with in the past?
-Yeah, I had done one scene
with J.K. in a movie
that I starred in years ago
called "Astronaut Farmer",
and J.K. was in that,
so I knew him a bit.
Bruce and I go way, way back,
and he's one of my mentors
and, you know,
people that I hold dear,
and it was great
to be with him again
because I've done,
you know, four or five things
with Bruce in the past.
And he's wonderful in it.
Both of them are.
It's -- When you've been
in this business a long time,
you kind of know everybody,
you know?
I mean, you and I met
when you were a fledgling
on "Saturday Night Live".
-My early days.
-Very early days,
-Early, early days, you know.
Bear Research. Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-And [clears throat] --
and so, when you're around
people like that,
sometimes you go,
"Oh my God, that's Bruce Dern."
You know?
And I knew
Johnny Cash very well,
and I -- it was like being
in the room with like, you know,
Fred Flintstone or something.
It's like, "Are you kidding me?
I'm actually in the room
with Fred Flintstone?
-Right?
-You know?
-And yeah, Bruce and I have had
an amazing time over the years.
He's been very, very good
to me and a mentor to me.
-Is this a situation based on
your friendship
that you call them up
and say, "There's a part for you
in this season of 'Goliath'?"
How does it work?
-Yeah, it kind of works
that way.
You know, Larry said to me,
"You think Bruce would do this?"
And I said, "I don't know,
I'll call him."
And he said,
"Yeah, I'd love to."
Yeah, it was kind of like --
it was that way with Dennis,
also, and Dwight Yoakam
in the first season.
There are several people
who we've sort of talked over
over the years in the series
and since had
a personal connection with them.
Like in season two and three,
we had Paul Williams.
You know,
and he was a buddy of mine,
and they said, "Who would you
get to play this part?"
And I said, "Paul Williams."
They said,
"You mean the songwriter?"
I go, "Yeah, trust me."
-Well, I guess the first time
I saw Dwight Yoakam act
was probably "Sling Blade",
right?
I mean, had he done anything
before that?
-He had. He'd done a couple of,
you know, independent films.
And Dwight --
actually, it's funny
because I started out in music
and became an actor,
and Dwight started out in the
theater program at Ohio State
and became a musician.
You know,
it was really funny, but...
Dwight was a good actor. I mean,
I'd seen the, you know,
smaller things he'd done
before we did "Sling Blade",
and I knew he was --
he was a dandy.
-He must -- I'm assuming
he's a far nicer person
than he came off in
"Sling Blade",
because I got to be honest,
I was really happy how it ended
for him in that movie.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dwight -- Dwight did a great job
as an ass [bleep].
He sure did.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, and I have to say, I mean,
before we get off of this thing,
I kind of like this Zoom idea.
You know, it's not a bad thing.
And the main reason
is because I don't really
like to wear pants.
-Yep.
And, I -- You know, well,
I won't -- I won't say
the rest of it, but --
-I think we got it.
I think we can all finish it
from there, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Well, I think we can.
You know, you just put
a big flannel jacket on
and enjoy yourself.
[ Laughs ] Well, I think we've
all enjoyed ourselves
and it's always great
to see you.
You know what?
And when we're in studio,
we'll figure out a pants-free
existence for you here, too.
-Absolutely. You can just --
You know how you guys, like,
you know, blank stuff out?
-Yeah, we'll just blur it.
All right. Thanks, Billy Bob.
Always a pleasure.
The fourth and final season of
"Goliath"
is available now
on Amazon Prime Video.